bismillah alhamdulillah makin peace be
with you we have an exciting show like
we always do here on the Deen show with
a brother who went from being a
Pentecostal Christian to the Zulu Nation
what's the Zulu nation we're going to
find out about that he went to Medina to
study and he came back right after 9/11
and we're gonna get his thoughts on that
and we're gonna get his thoughts on why
he accepted Islam we're going to ask him
some tough questions here on the Deen
show with our brother Wesley LeBron his
story here on the Deen show be here with
us don't go nowhere to hear this
incredible story we'll be right back
this is the team
[Music]
this is the things is the theme this is
the things the engineer I'm the Dean
show we're back with Wesley LeBron
soliloquy
waalaikum Salaam peace be with you and
peace be with you how are you I'm real
everything's got all praise and mercy
all praise is due to Allah and wa taala
so you found the time to be with us here
on the Deen show you have an incredible
story you accepted the way of life of
all the messages of God that completes
submission to the will of the one
creator who created you me this whole
universe and everything in it but before
that you were in the Zulu nation
Pentecostal part of Christianity you
know hanging with the homeboys and you
even went to Medina for a little bit to
study and now you're here on the Deen
show where do we start we can start up
before Islam briefly talk to us know
before Islam I was raised Pentecostal in
a Pentecostal family very religious
family raised by my grandmother because
my father was an immigrant to this
country in my teens I started to pull
away from religion I started to think
about Jesus Christ and him being a man
and walking on the earth and I had a
problem with worshipping him so I
started worshipping God and then of
course being in middle school high
school got involved with friends and
partying and then started selling drugs
and being out in the street and hanging
out so religion just completely left my
mind altogether until my mother she used
to raise foster children and this one
kid that was came up in our home named
Edgar his mother had died of AIDS his
father was in jail for most of his life
he was 17 years old he introduced me to
the Zulu Nation in New York he said look
as this organization the Zulu Nation I
would like to take you up there so that
you can go ahead and get to see what
it's about in Afrika Bambaataa who was
big in hip hop he was the leader he was
doing they used to give the meetings so
we decided to go up with him to New York
and when went up to New York we said
dan was listening to the meetings a lot
of the meetings basically dealt with
government conspiracies and things in
his nature
they had principles but they were a gang
in reality part of that was that a
gentleman named Aziz a Muslim brother
who was also Puerto Rican like myself
and Edgar he came and he said can I talk
to you brothers after giving a short
speech to all of the members of the Zulu
nation and we said sure
Edgar knew him from years back when he
was with the organization all of the
gang and he said look I would like to
talk to you about a lot he said would
you mind taking me home so I told me
fine let's go I'll take you home so he
lived in the Bronx so we went to his
house he invited himself for some coffee
and some tea and he began to talk to us
about Allah the one God he began to tell
us that Allah didn't have a father Allah
didn't have a son that allowed them to
have any family members that he was the
creator of the heavens and the earth and
all that existed and I said man I said
in my teens this is what I believed in I
couldn't pray to Jesus because I had a
problem praying to a man and when I
looked at the scriptures it just didn't
all fall into line for me so I said do
you have some more information about
this so he gave me a book tell he'd my
bilal philips what does this mean talk
so he basically means the oneness of God
I know what it means this for our
audience how he basically means the
oneness of God praying and worshiping
the one God the one true created the one
who created the heavens and the earth
the one who is free from association
no one he has no equals no partners as
he says in the Quran Allah said
committee sheikh husam you know about
see there's nothing like a nothing so I
took this book on cell he'd me Edgar and
another friend of mine and we would sit
down and we'd have lessons and reading
this book and we started to delve more
into it and at the same time we started
to read it on the Nation of Islam and
then we started to read up on the five
percenters then we started to read a
book called from [ __ ] to gods so we
started to read also yeah I mean that's
it was an actual book a book this is not
this is a book called that name this is
a book actually from [ __ ] to gods that
a particular type of five percenters
used to study so a religion is based on
this book what are they study this book
a following studies this potato five
percenters they follow this book that
the name you just wonder they follow the
book of now I'm not sure I didn't really
get too much into the depth of it we had
picked it up and we started to read all
these books because we wanted to compare
we started to compare I said before I
can accept anything I have to give
Christianity a chance this is the faith
that my family came from this is what I
was raised in I was really spent at
costume so I have to give it a chance so
I read the Bible from cover to cover
upon reading the Bible from cover to
cover
I had my highlighter in my hand and I
would highlight all the verses that I
found to be problematic for me and then
I would go to the church and I basically
asked the pastor at the church what
about this verse what about that verse
what about this verse and all of the
answers they were never satisfactory so
you sincerely you went up to the
higher-ups does the priests or whoever
the higher clergy in the church and you
were like talk to me that's not making
sense and you're asking them and wanting
these sincere answers and they couldn't
it could give me as would give you rest
for you for your for your soul my fault
my soul didn't find rest and out as my
grandmother's well because she was very
religious about ask my aunt was over
some of the questions you would ask
basically the monumental questions was
you say Jesus is God those verses in the
Bible where he says oh goodness
mason's why thou call me good when the
only one good is that one in heaven I
said he always referred back to God he's
always referring back to God he prayed
he went into the garden he bowed and
posture aided his face into the ground
and he prayed to God he did didn't he he
did that's in a I believe that's in
Matthew 26:39 that he fell on his face
and he prayed to God unto the one God
yeah and then also the biggest one for
me was when I was sat down in the church
and the pastor said the Jesus is the one
and only true God so after that I posted
my second I asked you a question
I said Jesus is the only one a true God
I said but when he was supposedly on the
cross he said my God my God why hast
thou forsaken me I said so you have the
God whom Jesus was crying to and then
you have your God that you're saying is
Jesus so which one who should I pray to
he looked at me confused and he said son
you just have to believe I said that's
not a good answer for me I said a God
has given us a mind to tell me that I
just have to believe and there's no
proof there's no evidence Jesus is
calling upon a god you're telling me to
call upon Jesus I find it more
comfortable to call upon the God that
Jesus called upon makes sense it makes
total sense
so upon seeing those things and go into
the church and asking those questions
and continuing to read this book on tell
heed we came to the final conclusion
that yes we wanted to become Muslims so
we went back to New York to another
meeting for Zulu nation and then we met
with the brother Aziz until the look
we're interested in accepting Islam and
at that point I actually actually showed
us a movie called the message about the
Prophet Muhammad may peace and blessing
of Allah be upon him we watch the movie
and it put more certainty in our heart
and then we became Muslims we took
Shahada that night what you have to do
to become Muslim to become Muslim you
have to take the testimony of faith
basically saying shadow and Hillel
shadow and o Muhammad Rasulullah which
basically means I bear witness that
there is no God worthy of worship except
Allah and that Muhammad is the final
messenger and prophet said by Allah I
found this statement so profound because
it if you connect it back to Jesus's
time Moses his time Abraham time is the
same statement saying there's no god but
the one true God nothing worthy of
worship except the one true God and
everything we just say a lot Aramaic
jesus at allaha and Jesus was the
messenger at that time Moses at his time
Mohammed now at this time yep that's the
statement right that's the statement the
one universal message that he carried
and that's the message that we found to
be universal within the Bible itself and
that's what gave us the conviction to
become Muslim so what goes on from there
from there after that you know we still
was dipping and dabbing in this because
we were new Muslims so we didn't really
know much unfortunately so we still
partied we still drunk unfortunately and
Aziz the brother he came to us and had a
talk one day he said listen you can't
have your cake and eat it too you can't
have your cake and eat it too how you
want to accept the truth but you're
going to do opposite of the truth it
doesn't work exactly he said you can't
come to the Zulu Nation meetings no more
you can't continue to go ahead and party
drink and have fun and worship a lot at
the same time but what's this you
mentioned you accepted Islam but Zulu
nation how does this fit in well the
Zulu nation what happens was humble ah
all praises to Allah we didn't get to
stay long
with that gang this relation it was a
short period but when when we accepted
we didn't know if we wanted to leave
histo because they talked about a lot of
government conspiracies and they draw
interest but in then when I Z so listen
you know you can't have both you either
going to be religious are you going to
deal with this junk over here because at
the end of the day it was again
and and the underlining principles were
no good so we said to ourselves okay
we're going to choose a loss of Panama
teller we're going to choose to be
religious and he told us don't come back
to New York anymore he said find a
mosque in your area because we're from
New Jersey originally he said find a
mosque in the area where you go there
call me let me know what they're
teaching and then I'll tell you what
their teaching is correct and then stay
there at that place don't come up here
no more and change so we did that we
went to Paterson New Jersey
we found the mosque we stood out in the
parking lot and we were kind of nervous
at first he's like man this is something
new we left we didn't go in we came back
the second time we said okay let's go in
so we went in the mosque it was actually
a Palestinian Masjid when we walked in
everybody speak in Arabic no English
everybody's talking words just stood on
one acre may peace be upon you just a
little head may Allah reward you all
these words and we're sitting there you
know astonished because we didn't know
what these words meant we're going to
we're going to get into some of the
definition of these were common use
words that you've heard and we got so
much more to talk about here in the Deen
show with our brother your brother Abdul
Sameach here on the deed shall be right
back everybody in deep down they believe
that there is a God yeah and as much as
they deny
if God exists and he does if God sends
prophets and he does if God reveals
books and he does should he not tell me
how to live my life doesn't that make
sense they feel more secure and safe now
inside the religion of Islam than they
ever felt out in the streets
the best way to bring true profound
happiness trooper found peace trooper
found tranquility is by following the
guidance that God has given see for
yourself what Islam has to say because
it really is the path to happiness and
truth in life back here on the Deen show
with Abu Samia formerly Wes Wesley
LeBron yes correct
what like Wesley Snipes like Wesley
Snipes and like LeBron James yeah so why
did you change your name well when we
first accepted Islam you know it was a
big thing I walked in and met Muslims
and everybody has these different names
and we started to find out what they
mean so a good friend of mine who
accepted Islam with me Tony
he said we started looking at the
attributes of Allah so one of the
attributes was Abdul Razak which meant
the provider of the servant of the
provider meaning Allah so he said you
have kids you're always providing for
your kids you're always taking care of
people you're always helping people out
why don't you take this on as an
attribute for yourself in that way is a
constant reminder for you of what you
should be doing so I said wow that's
great
I said yeah definitely so I took on the
name of Donald Zack at that point and
then they call me Abu Somalia which
basically means the father of Somalia so
my youngest daughter her name is Somalia
your daughter's Samia Abu Samia so our
you know viewers who are not Muslim they
can better understand the exact so
there's meaning behind these names
definitely yeah it's definitely me okay
so tell us now continue on let's just go
back real quick the Zulu nation but so
they had some somebody took some of the
teachings of Islam but technically do
they have anything to do are they what
do they have this is not a sect I mean
this is a sect of Islam what are they
know abou is Afrika Bambaataa he came in
to Aslam but he thought Islam was
nationalism uh-huh but when he found out
that it was a nationalism then he when
he made his own form of concoction I
don't even know what you want to call it
because when used to go to the meetings
basically he would allow different
people from different faiths to stand up
and pray and after those all those
prayers went on and then he would get to
the meeting at hand would be to talk
about the government conspiracies and he
was a big follow of dr. York which I'm
not sure if you're familiar dr. York dr.
York was basically someone who started
ansarullah
that's how he started in New York and
they started out as Muslim
and then they change to be Jews and then
they change to be Cowboys I think it was
and then now then they changed to be
Egyptians and he actually built like
pyramids and I think it's Alabama I
think it is more somewhere out there
it's down south and he had his own
teaching he said that he was a prophet
he said he was the manatee basically he
was saying that he was the one whom you
had to follow basically so this is
basically like Zulu nation nation and
all these other people who are trying to
be under the birla Islam they have
nothing this is nothing to do they have
nothing to do with Islam nothing to this
Lomb is Islam Islam is Islam okay so
continue on with your story you know you
go from Pentecostal Christian it's not
making sense to worship a man you want
to worship the one who created Jesus the
one whom Jesus prayed to so and you get
hooked up with the Zulu Nation you you
end up they end up sending you to a
mosque in your area New York what
happens from there
so basically from there I went into the
mosque you know like I said they walked
in and these people using all these
different terms in Arabic the Imam the
leader of the Masjid he was talking in
Arabic because all of his constituents
would make basically Arabs so I said man
I made a mistake I said I came into this
faith I said I don't speak Arabic I
don't understand what like I'm Puerto
Rican I want to be exactly exactly and
it just so happened that when we came
out of the mosque that they walked into
the hallway we seen two guys in the
hallway they had hoods sweat hoods on
they looked like they were from the hood
so I said hold on I said let me go talk
to him you know it looks like I could go
ahead and get along with these guys this
is a did they come from where I come
from so when I went up to them they were
actually from Guatemala two brothers
from Guatemala who accepted Islam maybe
a few years before we did so they told
us look there's an American mosque about
a mile from here you maybe feel more
comfortable if you go there so I said
okay he gave us the address and we
decided to go there but before we went
there we actually took some time because
like I said we were still involved in
the street and it was this was a little
much for me was walking this step was a
little much so one day we picked up a
friend from the projects and I see two
men walking african-american men and
they had fobs on was the Arab culture
where the white long garment that looks
like a dress so I looked at him and I
said yo I said who was this so my friend
who accepted Islam with me Tony he said
those are Muslims
that I know except at the wrong faith
now I said I can't walk around here
wearing dresses they crazy
what's wrong with them I said ah man
this is crazy so we decided said look
let's go to the American mosque in
Paterson the other one and see she was
going on and lo and behold when I walk
in the same man that I saw at the
projects with the thumb and the white
dress on he was the Imam there and it
just so happened that we sat down and we
began to talk to him and that became a
long beautiful friendship that I had
with that it particularly men so one day
it just so happened I was at home
drinking smoking with friends and we
sent out on my porch while we sent out
on my porch I'm looking into the sky I'm
just looking at the moon I'm looking at
the Stars it's about 3 o'clock in the
morning and the story of Ibrahim I had
read it in the Quran just recently about
him talking to his people talking about
the Sun must be my lord look at how
strong it is and when the night covered
the day he said must that can't be my
luck because verily is weak so I start
contemplating on this story and I said
if I don't change the law is going to
destroy me at that moment I told my
friends get up get out of my house
they said what are you talking about you
drink you get high now you don't know
how to act I said no this is the first
time in my life that I know exactly what
I'm doing I said get up and leave at
that point I knew that I had to cut off
all of my friends this was in the middle
of the party now this was in the middle
of a gathering yeah and I said you got
to go uh-huh
were they Muslim they weren't Muslims ok
I was hanging around a bunch of
non-muslims and I said you got to go but
they weren't good influencer for you now
they were still there supporting the
drink in the smoke in and calling me to
him yeah calling me to it and that's why
I said I have to cut them off and you
really want to become a better human
being and I wanted to be a better person
I wanted to be a better man I want to be
a better father I wanted to be a better
worshiper to my Creator so I knew that I
had to get away from them so I cut them
off I left him alone and I dumped me but
my second home became the message it I
would go to work come out of work and go
to the mosque and I was staying the
mosque learning praying sitting around
the brothers so that I can go ahead and
begin to develop better character and
this began this became my life tell us
now
you took a major step a major leap
forward but
why why not just stay where you're at
hanging out it's fun people you know
drinking with the boys chasing the
ladies you know going to the parties to
the nightclubs now you have all a bunch
of do's and dont's yeah you got to get
up at a certain time and pray when it's
difficult to get up you can't you're not
supposed to be cursing lying deceiving
you know over here it's it's pretty it's
a pretty easy lifestyle this it takes a
lot of effort you know what I mean it's
a struggle why didn't you just stay with
the easy way why'd you choose this hard
way what an easy way it seems easy but
it's actually miserable you live in this
life that it seems to be something that
seems to be all about fun and partying
but the reality is is that there's no
fun is after it's all over you woke up
you had a hangover
you may have got a woman pregnant like I
did two times end up having two kids now
you got child support you know it has
consequences with it and then when I
began to live the life of faith it began
to become sweet sweet sweet life began
to taste so sweet
faith beginning to taste sweet I began
to feel like a person all over again I
began to feel free when I worshiped God
I was able to worship him with peace in
my heart I was able to walk around and
show my family my family when they saw
the change in me it was incredible at
first they didn't want to know nothing
about me you're Muslim get out of here
you worshipping the devil and then when
they seen that I stopped drinking that I
stopped smoking that I changed my life I
stopped womanizing and then they came to
me and said Hodos that's it down
was that not the same guy she said not
the same guy we've been trying to get
him to stop the whole time I didn't work
nothing work nothing worked but Islam
worked Islam worked why so much so that
my father one time he was at a hot dog
truck and the man was praying and when
the man finish praying of he said to my
father I'm sorry I'm Muslim officer no
my son his Muslim understand he said
where you from he said Porter we go he
said any sons Muslim he said what do you
think about Islam he said I can sleep at
night now your father could you cause so
much havoc yes your father could and
mother couldn't sleep but now you
accepted Islam the worship of the one
creator and now your character got
better your life got better
parents could finally get some rest yes
family can finally get some rest
anywhere peace were they worried now
also because you know all the false hype
that's out there that now you're gonna
you know go and hurt innocent people
terrorized people what about that
well what's amazing was that when the
hype kicked in I was actually a Medina
studying so you actually went down to
the Islamic University to Medina this is
how motivated you are you went to the
University of the prestigious University
to learn the religion what happened I
went to the prestigious University of
Medina learned the religion and I always
say that my that Allah did not send me
there to learn he didn't send me there
so I can become a scholar he sent me
there to change my life when I went
there I saw what worship was all about
it became clear to me that God is to be
surrounded that our life is to be
surrounded around God and not God around
our lives so I was there for about six
months 9/11 happened and my family was
here in the States
so I felt that I had to come back cuz me
and my wife were the only Muslims in our
family and I felt that she needed the
support being a new Muslim that I needed
to give her and we need to support each
other in this particular time and at the
same time I needed to be here to also
talk to my family and prove to my family
that listen this is not what Islam or
Muslims all about we're gonna take a
break we got a few more questions to ask
before we come to a close here on the
Deen show you don't want to go nowhere
with this exciting story
right back and if we're going to worship
something I figured I might as well
worship the Creator instead of any of
the creations now in upon investigating
the villages I remember finding out the
meaning of what Islam is what Muslim is
those who surrender their self to God is
a Muslim those who surrender submit to
God God's will die see Islam was pure it
was just you just pray to God you create
when outside everything looks good you
see the hundred thousand dollar cars you
see a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
no paradise right here are just not
anyone's job to go into someone's heart
to change their heart your job is to
topi what the truth is and the alley of
it is while we're sitting here while I'm
sitting here constantly paying for the
disease to kill was free I am not afraid
to stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone
I am Not Afraid to stay
[Music]
back here on the Dean show with
our brother and your brother Abu Sameach
talked to us now a few more minutes left
I want to ask you some tough questions
for the people now that are watching the
not-yet Muslims because everyone has the
potential to submit to only God the one
God the God that now you were searching
for you didn't even want to worship a
man you didn't want to worship Jesus by
the way are you like Antichrist now no
I'm not basically I'm for Christ if we
don't believe in Christ we don't believe
that's what our prophet taught us so we
love Christ just like we love Muhammad
we love Christ more than did more than
the Krishna - well is a bold statement
how can you back that up
of course definitely you know part of
Christ is in our life as well you know
many most many people think that we
don't believe in Christ that was the
first thing my family thought and then
we start to show them the proof there's
a whole chapter about Mary in the Quran
chapter 19 if we really speaks about
Mary it and about all the things that
Mary went through it speaks about Jesus
all the miracles that Jesus had all the
miracles that Jesus did everything that
Jesus taught so we look at it and
they're more detailed then when was in
the Bible I was able to talk to my
family about some of the miracles they
never heard none of these things they
were surprised mm-hmm so definitely we
show our love for Jesus we definitely
show up and someone might say oh he went
radical on us now what would you have to
say no way basically Islam is a religion
of peace it's a religion of mercy is a
religion of submission it's a religion
of being at peace with humanity you want
humanity to have that peace our religion
doesn't teach us to kill people I
realize another teacher to terrorize
people rather I really didn't teaches us
like the Prophet told us if you're the
best Muslim is the one who's good to his
neighbor that you should bring over some
soup to your neighbor you should get to
meet your neighbor you should get to
know who your neighbors are me and my
neighbor they tell me where their key is
hidden for their home if I'm not home
they tell me you can come to my house
check on my house for me this is what
neighbors are supposed to be this is
what Islam is supposed to do that if
you're supposed to be around in the
society and the people are supposed to
be filled peace and tranquil with you so
how did you feel when 9/11 happened when
9/11 happened I was upset naturally
because they blame the Muslims and of
course my family I first they would like
we're fighting the enemies
hold on I'm a Muslim sir mind am I the
enemy now and the most like ah hold on
no so it was it was baffling you know so
we had to come and teach them no this is
not what our prophet taught us our
prophet told us that the man who kills
himself kills himself in a suicide
bombing that he goes to hell there's no
permission in times of war we can't kill
innocent women and children you can only
fight the person who's fighting you you
can't build those homes you can't tear
the trees out of the front of the homes
you can't do none of these things so if
the person and it's a person you're
fighting stops then you're supposed to
stop as well wish to show that
self-restraint
this is what islam teaches us
amazingamazing tell us now for the
person who's still stuck where you were
and you know they're not happy that void
is there that there's an emptiness there
and they're still partying hanging out
at the nightclubs you know womanizing
and the women getting sucked up also
wanting the attention for the from the
man and you know becomes just a game a
never-ending cycle and what how would
you advise them my advice for them is
basically take the chance read about
Islam read about Nepal and read about
Muhammad sallallaahu are you solemn may
the peace and blessings of Allah be upon
him give yourself a shot you deserve
better as a human being as a person you
deserve more in your life than partying
drinking being with men being with men
women give yourself a shot
pray to God he's the one who created you
your we're living in this existence
because of him we breathed every day
because of him what you have is because
of him he's the one who provided for you
so you have to go ahead to seek after
him you have to find out who he is find
out what he expects of you and then
fulfill that amazing tell us now we're
almost out we got one minute left you
also are continuing also your education
you are worth that what's the new name
of the University I'm with Mischka
University which used to be the shitty
Academy of America and basically I found
them in 2006 and continue studied
studying Islam about have about 10
courses left for my BA in Islam and I
think that for those who are looking to
learn more about Islam I think this is a
good
source for you you're also the president
of the Latino Muslims of Chicago yes the
president of Latino Muslims in Chicago
we have monthly classes that we have a
ICC I here in Chicago the first Saturday
of every month that wonderlocke first
Saturday of every month one o'clock the
lectures are all in Spanish because we
want to reach out to the Latino
community and be able to give back to
them how do people get a hold of you if
they wanted more information on the
Latino Muslims in Chicago or Islam in
general Islam Latino Muslims Latino
Muslims Chicago at gmail.com okay but
they don't have to be Latino maybe they
want to talk they can relate to you they
you know I've been through you know some
of the things that you've been through
and you know what it's late at night
early in the morning they're like man I
need to change my life I can identify
with this guy I need to talk with them
so they can reach you there you can
reach me there you can hit me up on
Facebook I Musume a LeBron at Facebook
and you can send me a friend alfe right
leo and we can sit and talk if people
invited you to come out to their town to
their city also to do you know talk
about you know extended talk about your
story you'd be willing to come I'll
definitely know I'm more than willing
all right
may allah the creator of the heavens and
ever awards you immensely for sharing
your story with them maybe less lucky
for all the good work that you do I mean
Thank You slamming uppercuts and that
was another exciting episode I'm sorry
we had to come to an end I know you'd
want us to continue more it was very
exciting and I hope that you got to
benefit and if you're tuning in for the
first time know that we're here every
week we're here helping you develop a
clear lucid understanding about the way
of life that was sent for all of mankind
to live by peace acquired by submitting
your will to the one who created you
that's Islam that's the message that was
sent throughout time really understand
that we're not self-sufficient that
there is a purpose in life and we need
to live our purpose that that void
that's inside all of us cannot be filled
with drinking and partying and just
going out there and living according to
your whims and desires that will never
make you happy but when you truly
surrender yourself to the one who
created you have a relationship with the
one who created you his way not your way
that's how you can truly be successful
when you live your purpose according to
God's will not your desires and it
starts with acts asking
and when you ask you shall receive so
ask the Creator to guide you and help
facilitate away he'll facilitate away
god-willing continue to tune in here to
the Dean show we're here to help you you
can call us at